die sogenannte epidemische lage sie
läuft im november aus und das heißt ja
auch ausnahmezustand weil dieser zustand
eben die ausnahme sein soll aber bild
liegen jetzt pläne vor die diesen
ausnahmezustand möglicherweise zur regel
machen könnten paul ronzheimer bild vize
bei uns im studio corona ausnahmezustand
für immer ist roter die ganz große
mogelpackung kai die große corona
mogelpackung denn eigentlich wollte jens
spahn eine gute botschaft senden an alle
deutschen in den vergangenen tagen ja
die krone die epidemische lage die soll
nicht verlängert werden jetzt gibt es
wieder freiheit und so weiter und so
fort und da denkt man dann hört sie
eigentlich auf also irgendwann keine
masken mehr
abstand all diese dreijährige die wir
jetzt was seit zwei jahren befolgen
müssen doch irgendwann mal aufhören aber
nein es geht eigentlich darum dass diese
maßnahmen also zum beispiel maske tragen
abstand halten auch ohne ausnahmezustand
angewandt werden können das bedeutet
dass am ende ist keine verlängerung
braucht um diese maßnahmen durchzuführen
und auf welcher weise ist kann man das
einfach machen welche hintertür wird da
gerade geöffnet da gibt es gerade ein
gesetzesentwurf aus dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium der das
möglich machen soll und das spannende
daran ist bislang hören wir auch von der
fdp gar nichts dazu also ich frage mich
wo ist der große wolfgang kubicki so
haben wir ihnen damals genannt heute
wiedergewählt zum vize bundestags
präsidentin der gesagt hat und immer
wieder gesagt hat das muss aufhören
freedom day also ich finde die fdp ist
jetzt gefordert da klartext zu sprechen
und sagen ende und christian lindner hat
das ja hier schon gemacht vor anderthalb
wochen in der richtigen fragen hatte
angekündigt dass man das nicht mittragen
wird dass man die epidemische
notlage sozusagen nicht weiter
verlängern wird das heißt auch da droht
die mogelpackung du hast gerade dieses
papier diesen gesetzesentwurf schon
angesprochen werden kurz gezeigt
vielleicht noch mal erläutert was was
ist das und was steht da konkret drin
also ist bedeutet das hier sehen wir ihn
noch einmal dass eine der umgang mit der
epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite und da sehen wir die
verschiedenen ausführungen dazu
zusammenfassend ist es so das ist keine
ausnahme
mehr braucht um zb das maske tragen und
weitere freiheitseinschränkung
weiterzuführen und hier rot in diesem
papier bedeutet noch da wird noch ein
bisschen dran geschraubt das ist noch
nicht endgültig die parteien stimmen ab
wer entscheidet eigentlich am ende weil
jens spahn hat ja keine mehrheit mehr
bundestag das heißt er muss sich jetzt
irgendwie mit einer ampel mehrheit
dadurch retten die sind aber dafür oder
dagegen oder wer beschließt es da haben
sich noch nicht alle genau festgelegt
aber tatsächlich ist es so dass am ende
die ampel ganz entscheidend wird dafür
und da stellt sich die erste corona
frage also steht die fdp zu ihrem
freiheits thema womit sie am ende auf
eine zweistellige prozentzahl glaube ich
zumindest gekommen sind im
bundestagswahlkampf also halten sie wort
und machen wirklich eine andere corona
politik oder einigen sie sich auf diese
mogelpackung viele politiker mit denen
ich spreche in diesen tagen sind wieder
alle ganz besorgt weil die zahlen nach
oben gehen wenn man sich dann anschaut
wie die lage in den krankenhäusern ist
da muss man sagen daher ist kein
notstand